to set the record straight the
bachelorette conversation did happen on
the bus from the airport in Singapore to
the hotel it was just talking about
being the Bachelorette or one of us
winning and one of us being the bachelor
out after this and honestly like it was
the word winning
I didn't felt like he was something to
be won I felt like it was a relationship
to work for there was a lot of talk
about this conversation you and Cassie
had and if you could like just quickly
clear it up yeah I know exactly the
conversation that was had I was fully
confident in my relationship with Colton
I was fully confident that it was gonna
be me in the end and I was terrified
that if it was me at the end I didn't
want Cassie and his friendship to be in
jeopardy and so I was like if it is me
at the end if I am engaged to Colton you
know I want you to be the Bachelorette I
want you to find your person I want you
to find happiness and she said the same
thing there was everything else is just
made up well watching you go home was
really difficult do you feel like you're
still confused about that and are you
still in love with Colton at this point
I'm so confused
I asked I you know I had one question
that I wanted to ask Colton and I asked
that tonight and we couldn't you didn't
really give me an answer he didn't give
me anything we all kind of sat in
silence for a minute and soaked that in
that there was no answer and I you know
taking some time and I've tried to heal
my heart but it has been lonely I
there's no one you can really talk to
about it it's been the hardest
heartbreak that I've ever had to deal
with and I thought it was over it um but
tonight just reopened old wounds are you
still in love with Colton I don't think
I'm still in love with Colton I just
think that I'm still processing this
deep deep love that I had for him why do
you think you were sent home and I have
to say was it hard to watch Cassie stay
she's your friend and she had not
expressed the same level of feelings for
him that you had I was surprised
Cassie and I the way that we managed our
best friendship so well is because um
we separated our friendship and our
relationship and so she didn't really
talk that much about her relationship
but she did say that you know we both
kind of felt that my relationship was a
little more further advanced than her so
I was surprised that I was sent home and
not her but you know he knows what he
wants
well a lot of people calling for you to
be Bachelorette yeah what is the status
of those discussions are some talks
happening about a potential bachelorette
moment I don't know who they are picking
to be Bachelorette
I just know have they talked to you
about it maybe happening I have not been
in this discussion okay all right well I
know a lot of people would love to see
it sounds like you would maybe do it
you'll see open to it tonight was rough
this process is rough yeah I don't know
[Music]